بسرعه رياح تجاوزت 185 ميلا في الساعه
الاعصار موار يتحول الى اقوى اعصار في
العالم عام 2023
الاعصار الفائق اجبر بايدن على اعلان حاله
الطوارئ بعد ان ضرب جزيره غوام
الجزيره البالغ عدد سكانها
168 الفا تضم ثلاث قواعد عسكريه امريكيه
تسبب الاعصار بدمار هائل في الجزيره امر
دفع السلطات لاعلانها جزيره منكوبه
وكاله الارصاد الامريكيه حذرت من تشكل
موجات كبيره قد يصل ارتفاعها 15 قدما
مع توجه الاعصار الى الفلبين يتوقع ان
يتكثف مع مروره غربي المحيط الهادئ
توقعات خبراء الارصاد الجويه تقول ان
الاعصار سيشتد ليصبح اكثر قوه ودمرا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات